trishelle coming back to our television
screens this is your first time back on
reality tv and how long has it been
almost 10 years oh my god what what
compelled you to come back
so mark long has been a friend of mine
since like i don't know almost 20 years
and so whenever he came to me and was
just like i had this idea for like oh
geez like
all the old people that we were friends
with back in los angeles to do a show
together like a challenge
i mean of course i was gonna be in
because these are my people
you are all put together for one
ultimate battle
to see who is the greatest
of all time what was it like the day you
like see like tj lavin you're in the
gear like how surreal was that
so this is funny actually whenever we
first got to argentina
and we go to meet up with tj um i was
told to just like you know dress like
normal like how you would normally do to
like go to dinner or something so i'm
wearing a
sequin dress my hair is all fixed curls
everything
i go and we're in the middle of the
woods like we're dropped off in the
middle of the woods in a bus
i'm sitting on a like a stump and
tj's there and everybody else is in
tennis shoes and like running clothes
and i'm in a sequin dress so this is
pretty much just
yeah it tells a lot about me how i felt
about the show so
is tj lavin still fine though i'm so
excited to see him yes he's amazing and
whenever he
gets there he's of course like
terrifying me he's talking about how
hard the challenge is gonna be
and i was just like no tj don't do it i
knew
automatically whenever i saw him that it
was going to be
terrifying so like all the challenges
are just way harder than i thought they
would be
so what happened after you left the show
because you kind of you like
quit tj lavin's like we don't like
quitters did you guys have beef by the
way when you see him
no i think that he was i knew that i had
to prove myself a little bit with him
though you have to earn tj's trust back
whenever you
like quit or he hates that so yeah i had
to get back into tj's good graces
um so since the rivals 2 um i've moved
around a little bit i was playing
professional poker for a while
i was traveling the world i lived in
montreal for a bit
like playing poker there finally moved
back to new orleans
and met my husband and now i'm married
and i live in new orleans
that's my thing so how would you say
you've changed since the last time we
saw you on television
well i want to say that i've calmed down
a bit but if you watch the challenge
you'll see that
i'm still kind of feisty um i mean
i think i've changed in the fact that
you won't see me hooking up with people
on tv anymore because i'm married and i
love my husband
um but i'm still the same person like
i'm still wild i still have a
feisty personality i have a good time um
so
i wouldn't say like too much has changed
i have not lost my edge in my age
well i know when i go back to my
hometown like i revert
to being like a 20 year old and just
like act and
does that effect happen when you guys
all get together like are you like oh i
thought we were like beyond this but now
we're just acting crazy again
one thousand percent yes uh whenever i
was on the plane to the challenge i was
just like oh my god like okay we're
really gonna wild out now right and like
we were all kind of like having fun
and then whenever we got there i was
like oh everyone's gonna like be on
their best behavior and calm down
that did not happen everyone was crazy
this season's gonna be so dramatic
um i really think it's gonna be it's
gonna outshine the challenges with the
younger people
wow so see that was my question because
i know when i watched the challenge back
in the day i'm really watching i'm
watching for the hookups i'm watching
for the cheating i'm watching for the
scandals i'm watching for the fights
like
that does that all that kind of stuff
still take place
every single thing that you just
mentioned takes place
we have a cheater among the group who is
it
i guess you're gonna have to watch oh my
god
this is gonna be an exciting season
really oh my god
that's uh that's the best tease you
could have ever given me i'm in
have you gone back and watched your past
seasons because they're all in paramount
plus
i know i've been watching them they're
so good still yeah i watched
every i watched my vegas season not too
long ago
uh i was trying to show my husband and
he fell asleep he thought it was boring
i don't know but uh but i thought it was
fun uh i watched battle of the seasons
the challenge that i did that i that i
got second place i don't know if that's
not a spoiler it already aired but uh
but i refused to watch the last show
that i did because i went off on such a
sour note that it's hard for me to watch
yeah so you the last we saw you you kind
of had this like
altercation with anissa yeah and then
you left
have you talked like so anise is in the
cast for this this season
yeah you guys discuss like what happened
oh yeah yeah we did
we did discuss it um so that was
something that
my stomach was in pits when i found out
that she was gonna be there because i
was just like wow
like this is gonna be an actual
face-to-face conversation that we're
gonna have
and so i knew that it was gonna come i
knew that it was something that i didn't
want to hide from
and i couldn't hide from and so like we
do have that discussion and i'm hoping
that they show it um
so yeah i would say look out for that
our fight
if you will but like that was the most
humiliating thing
even hooking up with my roommate on the
real world
even getting drunk on the surreal life
that was by far the most humiliating
moment i have ever
and the biggest regret of all the shows
that i've done
was that fight with anissa it was
horrible and so
yeah um i i did actually apologize to
her
via social media and then we do have the
conversation in person
on the new challenge oh that'll be nice
to like close the close the loop on that
yeah who did you stay close with over
the years i stay close with erisa
um she is she was on my cast and so i've
always been close to her
my friend katie doyle um
oh sorry my dog um katie doyle
and i uh who's on the new challenge with
us um she and i stay close mark long and
i have always talked um
so those are people that i was close to
going into the show
i love how your dog just came up and
blends in with the couch you can't even
tell there's a dog there anymore
i'm sorry he does this he owns this
place i don't know my
my dog's old it's so funny i've been on
so many interviews and dogs are always
in the shot and i'm like just keep them
there they're fine they're fine
okay so among the cast that's going to
be in the new season who are you looking
forward to
seeing the most beth is a really good
one because
i watched on paramount plus they have
like all the old school real worlds and
i started watching best season
um the real world los angeles i think it
was season two
um she is exactly the same
tech is amazing and ruthie from hawaii
real world
hisella is someone who i watched her
road rules but i didn't realize how much
i would love her until i actually met
her in person
so there's a lot of great characters i
mean everyone's surprised oh darrell
he's a challenge icon he's on the
current one that's airing now
he's amazing hilarious um yeah there's a
lot
the real world homecoming new york it's
great i love watching it
would you guys consider for the vegas
cast getting back together and doing
that i know you guys did a reunion like
five years after but now
i feel like we need another one but we
need another vegas reunion i think and i
think that this time if we did
another my cast as a reunion it would be
just so different there's so much more
to tell the stories have grown so much
between all of us
um i would absolutely love to do it i
talked to a few of my cast members and
they would like to do it as well
um i'm not sure everyone would be in but
hopefully
um i i mean i think that would be
interesting i feel like it would be very
dramatic i do
so now that you've done you've done the
challenge all-stars would you come back
and do another challenge now that you've
done it
uh i don't know it depends on what the
premise of the challenge is
this one was honestly so scary and so
hard uh
died it kind of terrified me i'm not
gonna lie like i have
like drama like dreams of like the drama
it was just crazy um i don't know maybe
maybe you will i'm not going to say
[Music]
never